[music]
Hey it's me Destin. Welcome back to Smarter Every Day. The cat is disturbing
homework time so we're gonna take a break and make an intro. So every time I've observed
a butterfly flying across a field he looks like he's a very poor flyer. He looks like he's bouncing
along and, because of the really large surface area on the wing and low mass it looks
like the wind's just making him flutter back and forth, like he doesn't really have control over what he's doing.
But it wasn't until I recorded this next video with a Miro at 2000 frames per second
in the Amazon that I realized that I've probably been wrong this entire time.
Alright, let's see if we can high speed.. What is this called? This butterfly?
- [unintelligible]
[music]
(Destin) Yep. I got it
Is it going?
[music]
It stayed in focus.
- Oh my god.
- Gee that was amazing.
Alright let's take this opportunity to change battery since this one's low.
Tristan you want some water?
- [unintelligible]
- Course you are. You don't need water do you.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.